now before we get to some of the worked
examples that are not just your basic
exponential or your basic
logarithmic curve i want to remind you
of these transformations because we've
been looking at them over the last week
they're kind of the focus of this topic
and i actually want to tell you about
one transformation that we've implied
but we actually haven't really dealt
with explicitly at least i haven't
perhaps you've done so
in your classes you might remember the
first two transformations we had to look
at last week
were the translation and
the dilation i wonder if you were saying
it aloud in your class i can't hear you
so i can't tell
now the whole idea here with translation
is it's a slide
you don't change the shape or size of it
you just change its position
right so when you have say for example
compared to y equals f of x
if you had y equals f of x
minus a what is that well that's the
same graph as f of x
but it's shifted a units
horizontally right in this case it would
be to the right so i'm just going to
write that down a units right
and if we wanted to translate vertically
instead of horizontally instead of
having that
that constant there minus a attached to
the x we would attach it to the
y because a vertical change is a change
in y right so i might have something
like
y minus a equals f
of x and that's not been shifted left or
right
that's been shifted a units
in this case oopsy daisy that's really
messy
in this case because it's a minus a it's
going to go
up and you could just as easily have
written that as
y equals f of x plus a okay so i hope we
remember this and i'm just going to give
you a quick visual cue so you can see
what's going on here right
here's a couple of curves right let me
make these a bit bigger
here's a couple of curves you can see
there it doesn't really matter what f of
x
is equal to it could be anything i've
just given you a cubic so you can see
the shape clearly
and then you can see in blue what i've
got is f of x
minus 2 just as an example value of a so
what are we getting here if i just get
rid of all of this you can see
the blue curve is the red curve but it's
been shifted two units
right as you saw in our table before and
if i did y
minus 2 equals f of x oh let's just do
it right
let's get rid of this minus 2 here and
put it over on the other side
minus 2. then predictably you can see
it's the same graph but it's been
shifted two units up
okay so this is familiar we're good with
this let's come back to our table over
here with dilation
how do we do a dilation you don't plus
or minus something right
if i had y equals f of x then to dilate
it
horizontally to stretch it in that
direction
you would instead of adding or
subtracting you would
divide or multiply right so if i had f
of x
divided by a that's not shift that's a
stretch
right compared to y equals f of x
this thing has been stretched i should
say is sorry there's a word missing
there
my grammar is not very good this morning
is
is we'll fix it one more here
is what do we say it's stretched and um
it's going to be by a factor of
a so it's a times taller sorry this is
wider actually
a times wider because it's an x
value so let me write y wider there
if instead of x divided by a you had x
times a then instead of being
wider you wouldn't be stretched out
you'd be compressed in you'd be squashed
in right
in the same way if i wanted to do a
dilation but i wanted to do it the
vertical direction
not the horizontal direction then
surprise surprise instead of
dividing x i will divide y so i might
have something like
y divided by a equals
f of x that's going to be stretched out
and it's going to be a times
taller in this case because we're going
vertically
and as i mentioned if you were doing um
you know
y times a instead of y divided by a then
instead of getting taller you would get
squashed in okay so let's
just quickly again confirm for ourselves
that this is what things look like
let's do a different function over here
so i'm over on the
on the right hand side i've got x
divided by say
two and if you have a look here
here's um our can we see more of that
graph
what's the best way to do it let's do it
vertically there we go okay so what do
you have a look at here red is the
original graph like we've seen before
what's the blue graph look like well i
have you can see made it wider right
it's twice as wide
i've stretched it out and if instead of
stretching out along the x-axis let's
move this number
this division rather over to the
y if i did y divided by 2
you can see as we just said in our graph
our table rather
this is the same graph but it's been
stretched out vertically so it's taller
okay and i encourage you by the way
if i'm going through this quickly or
you're like i'm still not comfortable
with this yet
please please please play around with
desmos and explore and have a have a
fiddle
um every single one of us teaches you
know we went through school and learned
all this stuff and we didn't have these
tools and it was a lot harder we just
had to graph everything by hand
so please use the technology you have
access to to
get a better sense of what's going on
now these are the two transformations we
looked at earlier you already knew how
to do those
but there's one kind of transformation
which we didn't talk about like i said
we just implied it
and if you think back to u7 there's one
that was missing right and that's
reflection so how do you reflect
a graph how do you do a flip on the
x-axis or the y-axis
some of you already know this from the
functions that we've been dealing with
for a while
if i wanted to do a horizontal flip
right how would i actually adjust this
thing well if it's horizontal
it's going to be attached to the x and
some of you already
sort of clicking together right to do
something opposite
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
slap a minus sign on there okay so maybe
this
rings some bells from when we're doing
odd and even functions so if i put a
minus sign on x
this is going to be flipped
and because it's on the x it's going to
be horizontally right
now the reason why i'm highlighting this
today is because these kinds of
flips and reflections are very very
common when you're dealing with
exponential graphs for example
if you have a think up above about the
exponential
growth of the population versus the
exponential decay of that carbon-14
radioactive situation that's a that's a
horizontal flip okay so we'll have a
look at those
and how to do that on your graph in a
second that's a horizontal reflection
how would i do a vertical reflection
well instead of putting a minus sign on
the x where am i going to put minus sign
i'm going to put it on the y right so if
i had say minus
y equals f of x
that's going to be flipped
but instead of horizontally it'll be
vertically
okay and as you can see i'll do this one
more time just for good measure if i
came back over to desmos here
let's put my pencil down for a second so
let's take
this guy here and pop a minus sign
and attach it to the x right like
so and you can see the blue graph which
is our new one right it is
sure enough a horizontal reflection of
our red graph which is our original
and i'll leave it for you to have a
fiddle and um do it with the uh
the vertical flip as well it's not too
complicated to see
all right now what that means is when
we're having a look at our exponential
graphs it really helps to have these
reflections sort of in your head so you
can have a think roughly
about what these things are going to
look like let's really quickly this is
just going to be a quick and dirty
sketch that you want to follow along
with
let's think about the differences or the
different kinds of exponential
curves you get if you do these
reflections right so here is
the exponential we did before so let's
call this y equals
2 to the x if i were to do a horizontal
reflection
i would have a minus x over there now
this is that situation i showed you with
carbon 14 right
when you flip this over left and right
you're not going to have a growth
situation
you're going to have a decay situation
like so
right so this is a fairly common graph
that you'll see that's a horizontal
reflection
what if i did sorry i started the same
color what if i did a vertical
reflection well you could either put the
minus sign on the y which i think is
where it belongs because
you're really changing things on a
vertical direction so it's y that you're
adjusting
or you could see it as y equals oops
y equals minus 2 to the x because of
course you could multiply both sides by
negative 1.
well what's that going to look like look
at the original exponential graph and
then see what happens when you flip it
upside down i'm drawing the bottom half
of the cartesian plane here because this
is the graph you're going to get i hope
you can see from the original
down to here there's the vertical
reflection happening right
and then lastly after the horizontal
reflection or the vertical reflection
you could of course
do both right so you could say i'm going
to put a minus sign on the y
and i'm also going to put a minus sign
on the x
so what is that going to look like well
let's do the bottom half here
it's going to look like this right
it's a bit of a bizarre kind of beast
now what situation would fit this i'll
let you have a think about it
but if you've got minus signs attached
to the y and attached to the x you're
going to get both reflections
happening